you were saying about how most parents
would be worried about their children
watching horror what I was so fascinated
by was how nice the people were at
monster Palooza oh yeah and we've been
to a lot of la film events and I mean
the people were super respectful not
just the staff I mean the actual horror
fans oh yeah
so it's interesting what do you think it
is about the horror genre that attracts
those fans and and what's sort of the
distinction between those and maybe
arthouse cinema fans or why think well I
think I think why people that love
horror movies are like very genuine
people very loyal people's because like
they're consuming so much like darkness
I guess they're consuming so much like
extremities inside of horror movies that
like that's enough for them where they
like they they they're almost like
purging them so I think like a lot of
like like some of the nicest people like
even like Wes Craven Sony who's like
such nice Pleasant people that make
these incredibly dark cynical movies you
know and like I think they're they're
getting it out and like whether it's
making it or watching it I think they're
um consuming law that but I think that's
like that's like their fix that they're
getting it's almost like a drug I think
that's why I think it kind of dictates
their personality a little bit maybe and
then like the people they're like the
biggest pricks are the ones that make
like the night like the happiest family
movies I thought I've realized I mean
but I mean I mean like our house I mean
like I mean I love all I love all sorts
of movies I mean like but our house I
mean like that there is sort of like
this really obnoxious pretension that
like I just not I just don't subscribe
to I'm just not I'm just like not I'm
just not a fan of it like like a lot of
you know it's like people that are very
feel like they're almost like above it I
feel like they're almost like above
certain kinds of like exploitation
movies are sort of like you know like be
movies even though hundred million block
dollar blockbuster movies are considered
to DB movies these days I mean like the
movie doesn't even exist anymore but I
mean like I think a lot of people are
just just so snobbish and then like
sometimes people think they're like
Allison I would like movies and all that
but it's like I'm snobbish about the
movies that most people are snobs about
not liking so it's like I I can I can be
a snob about those kind
oh you know but but I mean like just you
know it's III there's so many art house
films that I love I mean like I love the
art house John I mean like you know I
think Drive was I mean Drive was such an
incredible example of like art house and
commercial genre working so effortlessly
I thought and and I thought that movie
was just brilliant and and I was like is
like it can work really well I mean like
because like that's I am sort of attract
I'm much more attracted to a film like
drive than perhaps maybe like Fast and
the Furious I mean like drive is much
more my kind of like action movie
because I think it just has like art
house can really work inside of genre
because like you they sort of like
spread the action out so it's like more
impactful where it wears like these
other movies they're just like they have
almost like too much money so they're
just having like explosion after
explosion after explosion it's like you
know something's movies are just like
too big you know you can't like relate
to anything but yeah I mean like III
don't know I mean like the I I think
horrors like I mean it's never gonna go
away
I mean it's not it's it's been I mean
nah strut to I mean I was like 19 and 22
I mean I was late it's been I mean
horror I mean Horrors like been around
since like the dawn of movies almost and
and and it's I mean it's it's probably
the most like it's perhaps like what
most like like the most profitable
shanwa out there I mean like what
certainly one of the most and like it's
it's one of the few genres that truly
gets people to a theater that do much
better in theaters than like on DVD or
like on VOD I mean most of them do I
think and and there's just something
about or it's like it's the it's
watching something that you're not
supposed to be watching it's like a
forbidden sort of thought it's almost
like um a roller coaster kind of like
like a like a ride where like you're
it's it's a safe ride but it's still you
know kind of like could be a very like
shocking and and then and and going
going to a haunted house kind of feel to
it and that's why I just think horror
movies are just like there's nothing
better than going to see like remember
when I saw like the remake of like The
Hills Have Eyes back in like 2006 and
just like blew my head off like I was
like this is like such a ballsy
mainstream you know big like hefty
budget movie but like made by this crazy
French director that just like
complete light came from there's really
shocking movies and France and like God
that got the job to make one of these
like big mainstream or disguised as a
mainstream movie but it just got away
with some very bold stuff in it and
watching that movie in a multiplex like
it's like you weren't supposed to be
watching it like that that's the kind of
like I mean like Paul Verhoeven's like
when my idols and HIDA like Robocop and
showgirls and all that and Starship
Troopers and and I think he's um he's
like a career that I sort of like and
really fascinated by I'm sort of like
almost like one a model after sort of
like as a goal because like he what he
was he what he was able to do is that I
mean he was able to he makes these very
mainstream movies that are that are
clothed to be very mainstream and all
that but but he's able to his films are
also very politically incorrect his
films are very bold his films are very I
mean like Starship Troopers it's like a
100 million dollar fascist fantasy
monster movie and like you just get to
know everybody in the first hour of the
movie then he just like mutilates all of
them in five minutes and like it's just
I mean like that that that kind of like
boldness but inside of like mainstream
storytelling like I mean I think
Kingsman like the first Kings minute
came out a few years ago I thought that
was like kind of like a throwback to
that kind of movie cuz that movie was
like I loved that movie that was like
like that was a very bold movie on a lot
of levels but it was like getting into
our budget like some of the things they
got away with him at movie it was like
not a typical kind of it wasn't a
hundred percent what they I mean it
wasn't it wasn't what they marketed as
and like when people saw there's like
certain things in there there were very
divisive very polarizing to people but
overall it's like a fun movie but
there's like those certain scenes that
I'm like well I don't know that's gonna
be a little devices on some people I'm
like that's like that's always been I've
always been a try I've always been
attracted to like almost like
infiltrating the mainstream like I think
like that's like what I'm really I try
because I love straightforward story I
love mainstream movies like I love
commercial kind of movies but but sort
of a injecting a you know a boldness
inside of it because I think like
infiltrating the mainstream is when you
can like really like do some like damage
you know like in a good way you know
but yeah yeah I think uh yeah I guess
that's uh yeah but but yeah I mean like
that's yeah I mean like those kind of
those that just like you know just
sensational kind of movies or I think
because movies are all about like just
like I think entertain me in the
beginning like that's like the first
deformers you always have to like
entertain and then if you're hopefully
can have like a bold statement
underneath it like that's I think what's
always even more attractive to like have
a statement that's suggesting something
about the world that we're living in or
like the generation that we're living in
right now I think those are the kind of
movies that I think overall very tragedy
films that you know like um like I don't
know if there's like this film called
unfriended that came out it hasn't like
the Skype horror movie which covered I
know a couple people thought they liked
it ripped off like another movie but I I
just was looking at that film and I felt
like that was such a brilliant like home
run of a move Annie I know some people
didn't like it and because like they
hate movies that take place on a Skype
and all that but it's like that's a
generation we're living in right now so
it's like what else are they gonna do I
mean like and and and I just thought it
was so I don't think people like realize
like how well-made that movie was like
the editing just the details gives us
all through Skype it was like for Skype
cameras and like it was relevant it was
about like this girl that killed herself
and she's like haunting them and like
through the computers and and and it was
it was relevant about like bullying and
and and and teen suicide but it was also
like just also at the same time like
this like straight down the middle like
80 for a minute teen slasher
supernaturals the slasher film and and
and it was just like it was one of the
most purest teen slasher movies I'd ever
seen and like the fact that we're still
a having because everyone's trying to be
so like overly clever with like horror
movies and leg and I understand that
like but sometimes I think if like
things are a little too everyone's
trying to be like like scream or
something you know which is a you know
extraordinary film but like but I think
everyone's try always trying to do do
that again like like they they're always
trying to make their movie so I think
overly smart for their own good
sometimes and and I just think like I
wish horror films were a little
I think 824 is brilliant like I mean 824
like with like the which in green room
and and like the monster and this movie
hereditary coming out in June which
looks incredible and like there's movies
they're just like they're not they're
not really trying to be anything more
than they are but they're still like
this like weight behind them that makes
them feel like they're bigger than what
they are and and yeah I just like that
sort of like stripped-down simple
storytelling and nothing a twenty four
is really like excelling at that and
they're not trying to be like overly
clever you know they're just lay had a
concept and they just play it so well
with like very serious dramatic actors
and but they're very commercial kind of
genre concepts that they play most of
them but yeah I mean that's know thank
you for watching our interview with
Chris Vaughn Hoffman recently we've
begun hosting live events where we bring
together the film courage community if
you enjoy watching this channel we
encourage you to join us this upcoming
Tuesday October 23rd we have a class
with Pamela J Smith entitled mythic
challenges how writers can create
stories that change the world we think
it's going to be fantastic
check out the link below and hopefully
we'll see you there